redessinée avec le gouvernement un
accord avec le conseil scientifique de
combiner ces deux départements à savoir
est à une comptine may 7 jours sur 7
il fait bien mais vous aurez un
couvre-feu décalé à 19 heures on
pourrait également sortir de chez vous
toute la journée et sans limitation de
temps 10 km maximum de votre domicile
pourrait sortir bien entendu mais tout
sera fermée c'est donc allés nous mêmes
mesures a été prise hier par le
gouvernement en accord est coaché à bono
d'état et le conseil sont typiques
ce qui veut dire qu'on pouvait sortir
dehors marché et c'est tout quand vous
serez arrivé à l'endroit où devient
allez vous retournerez chez vous pouvez
faire des kilomètres d'accord pourrait
faire 10 km et gala mode dans la même
rue d'accord voilà donc c'est le
nouvelles consignes du gouvernement
donc voilà comment ça va se passer donc
qu'avez vous prévu donc ce week-end
gilles va aller marcher ça venir on va
s'appeler après heroes va marcher dit
qui y est c'est fait allez on y va on se
retrouve là c'est un truc de fois alors
donc là et la bonne nouvelle ou abc1
soyez sympa que le président de la
république on a quoi être au conseil
scientifique ainsi que franck provost
jacob et laboratoires schwarzkopf
collait si les coiffeurs ouvert jusqu à
nous alors c'est comment ils se sont
réunis ils ont ni vrai bon
euh c'est quoi tes coiffeur un les mecs
parce que là j'ai un délire moi je vous
cache pas la yamaha n échappe pas à
lever la balle au pied mais les gars ont
mâché un lissage brésilien mardi a donc
on fait comment un mois je veux bien les
mecs mais là j'ai une bar mitzvah j'ai
la bar mitzvah du petit benchetrit à tel
aviv vendredi prochain si je vais pas
par le lissage mardi je suis battu donc
bon écoute pour marlène en bas donc en
accord avec le conseil scientifique
garder les coiffeurs ouvert